first master getting up on top do that
for a week then let's add in you need to
learn how to do what's best for you what
you need to do in order to fight
overwhelm is you've got to actually do a
brain dump
Juanes or get a mentor what's up believe
nation eight seven I believe in you and
this channel is designed to be a part of
your daily success routine so today
let's learn from one of the best Mel
Robbins and some of her life-changing
advice mentor me Mel also if you want to
know what Mel and other successful
entrepreneurs have to say about building
unstoppable confidence check out my 250
for confidence series where every day
for the next 254 days I will send you a
morning video for free to help you build
your confidence the link to join is in
the description below I know that
everybody's problem comes down to one
pattern you're repeating that you can't
see when you set goals when you have an
intention on something that you want to
change about your life your brain helps
you if you didn't give what anybody else
thought what's the thing you would love
to be doing with your life
[Music]
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one wind of mourning so here's what
you're gonna do it's actually simple and
it's not gonna be easy cuz you're gonna
create all kinds of excuses and drama
for yourself okay you're gonna set your
alarm yourself and when the alarm goes
off that's what happened that gap is
gonna open up and you're gonna feel all
rolling I don't feel like it I'm over I
don't want to I don't feel like writing
a song anyway you know like that's when
you have to take control you have to
take control you have to get up every
morning it begins by getting up because
if you let anxiety excuses self-doubt
all the win in that first decision the
rest of the day is hides it so when the
first decision then exercise I don't
care about the eating as much I know
it's important that's put garbage in but
I would rather see you first master
getting up on time do that for a week
then let's add in exercise every day
ten minutes don't start with like two
hours because then you're gonna find an
excuse not to do it get up at seven
exercise for ten minutes then the third
week you're gonna add in like I'm
actually gonna eat clean this week or
whatever the diet is that you want to
eat right I'm just gonna add in things
as you master the little things but
you've got to get up on time it starts
right there rule number two try if you
had to pick one word that was you one
word that represented your essence and
so let me explain what I mean by essence
have you ever been around a dog that
gets wet and they shake and then there
gets all over you that to me is the
definition of essence so you walk into a
room what is it that shakes off on to
other people what's the word right here
excited anyone else determined time
energy back in the back to shut up
thoughtful
sexy awesome so it's interesting because
the word that fell out because I
immediately thought oh I wonder if mine
is confidence and then I thought well
wait a minute actually no it's try all I
want you to ever do is try that's it I
just want you to try in those moments
where you hear yourself I want you to
try in those moments where you know that
it's time to speak up I want you to try
that's all that I ever asked of you
because if you simply do that and I say
simply as if it's so easy right you will
literally unlock the potential of your
life rule number three make the best
decisions if your friend is facing a
problem when you have to make decisions
on behalf of your friend you tend to
think from multiple perspectives you
think about multiple outcomes and
ultimately you make a much better
decision what they found research though
is if they put you in the exact same
situation facing the exact same thing
that your friend is you're not able to
be so objective because you're emotional
and you don't make that creative
decision what's the conclusion well when
you make decisions for other people
you're great when we make decisions for
ourselves decisions that can be
emotional we're not so good at it that's
where the power of objectivity comes in
it's the ability to make a decision from
a third party's perspective
let me explain so if you're facing a
really important decision and you can
feel yourself getting emotional maybe
you're thinking about asking for a raise
or changing your career or changing your
major or ending a relationship or
starting a relationship whatever it may
be if it's something that is emotional
for you you're gonna have a hard time
thinking about all the options and
you're gonna be really attached
emotionally because maybe you're
concerned about the people who may be
impacted by your decision maybe you're
managing that somebody's gonna be
disappointed or hurt by what you need to
do for you this is when the power of
objectivity is really important pick
somebody that you really admire I mean
it could be somebody like a Bill Gates
or a Richard Branson or an Oprah Winfrey
or maybe have a mentor and stop yourself
and ask what would Oprah do in this
situation
what would Richard brand
do in this situation what would your
mentor do in this situation
bringing that level of third-party
objectivity will yank you out of your
body and your emotions and it will help
you give yourself the perspective that
you need and the distance from your
emotions so that you can actually assess
your options and make the best decision
for you
what would Mel do if Mel were making
this decision the best decision you know
there's a really interesting example of
somebody who did this in sports and at
the time he actually got a lot of flack
for it it was LeBron James now LeBron
James as you know played for the
Cleveland Cavaliers for a really really
long time and he's arguably one of the
best basketball players to ever hit the
NBA so he made this announcement that he
was going to leave the Cleveland
Cavaliers where he had been playing for
ever had rabbit rabbit fans he was gonna
leave them and go to Miami Miami Heat
that was the conclusion you woke up with
this morning that was the conclusion of
what was his moment he was giving an
interview to ESPN and what he said was
this he said LeBron James needs to do
what's best for LeBron James
now people kind of laughed at him
because it's a funny way to say the
sentence but this guy's really smart he
was leveraging the power of objectivity
Mel Robbins needs to learn how to do
what's best for Mel Robbins and you need
to learn how to do what's best for you
really before control how you live you
know I'm always looking for new ways to
explain the power of the five-second
rule and the power of five-second
decisions and I read something that Tim
Ferriss said that really resonated with
me and he had this one line buried in a
podcast somewhere that just jumped out
and it's it's it's stuck it and what he
said is he said something about how
there's a gap between the world and the
things that trigger you and your
response and your entire life is that
gap when you start to this is not what
he said he I kind of identified this gap
and I of course intrinsically was like
well absolutely that's the five-second
window between instinct or stimulus and
your reaction
and when you start to understand that
your whole life plays out in this
five-second gap and that there's a gap
that's five seconds long between fear
and courage and there's a gap that's
five seconds long between self-doubt and
confidence that is your life and what's
super cool about understanding that your
whole life is inside this gap is it's so
small everybody that you have the
ability to control it life's always
going to throw triggers at you and there
will always be all kinds of cool things
that inspire you your wisdom and you get
to choose what happens in that gap do
you succumb to an excuse or do you push
yourself forward when you start to speak
up in business you'll be shocked at how
you start to speak up and your
relationships when you start to make
hard phone calls whether it's in a
selling situation you'll be surprised at
how you'll start to close the gap and
have hard conversations in your personal
life and so that gap is everywhere and
it's the same everywhere and when you
start to go to work in controlling how
you live in that gap between stimulus or
idea and your response that's where the
magic is and rule number five the last
one before a very special bonus clip is
use a brain dump so let's pretend that
this right here this empty mason jar is
your brain in order to do your best
thinking you need to make sure that
you've got the full capacity of your
brain leveraged and pointed at the
things that are important to you here's
the problem when you go through life as
you go through life what happens is you
know your brain starts to fill up with
information and that's what creates a
state of feeling overwhelmed being
overwhelmed is nothing more than having
a full brain so as you go through your
day-to-day life and you start checking
email and looking at texts and looking
at Facebook and sitting in meetings and
flipping through television channels and
sending emails and writing Excel
spreadsheets and running and picking up
the kids at work and getting another
text and looking at Instagram and
looking at Twitter and checking out the
news your brain gets pretty full doesn't
it and so when you feel overwhelmed what
I know about you is that your brain is
full of a bunch of garbage and so oh I
didn't think about the drain draining I
hope that's not bothering you but
certainly gonna bother me what you need
to do in order to fight overwhelm is
you've got to actually do a brain dump
you got to get rid of all that stuff so
that you've got an empty brain so you
can focus again so how do you do that
it's easy to do with a cup of water
because you just pour it up this is what
you're gonna do you are literally going
to dump out everything that's in your
head onto this piece of paper every
concern every worry every to do every
thing that's bothering you that you're
thinking about you're gonna write down
[Music]
all right and when you're done writing
down everything that's in your head and
there's absolutely nothing left Oh got
something do tomorrow that I kind of
forgot about once you get that stuff all
down on a piece of paper pull out a
highlighter take a look you could do
everything on this list you could but
what should you do what are three things
just three that you should do in order
to advance the things that matter to you
let's see I got to do that one I gotta
do that one and I got to do that one the
rest of this list is complete and other
garbage it's other people's stuff it's
the email stuff it's the meeting stuff
it's the stuff that's not all that
important to me it's not that
mission-critical
so by dumping everything out I now not
only have the three things I need to do
I've got a clear head so I can get it
done
now I've got a special bonus clip with
Mel on how to use the progress principle
that I think you're gonna enjoy but
before that it's time for the three
point landing questions time to move
from just watching other video to
actually taking action in your business
or your life and if you're feeling bold
leave your answers in the comments below
here we go question number one
how will you start to win the morning
number two what are you going to just
try today and number three what
important decision will you make this
week
my life changed a couple years ago when
I discovered something called the
progress principle it is a principle
that was written about in the Harvard
Business Review it's based on a
tremendous amount of research done by a
professor over there and what she
determined is that people that feel
happy and successful and fulfilled by
their lives and work they all have one
thing in common they feel as though
they're making progress on something
that matters so I read this little bit
of research and I started applying it to
my life and what I do as as stupid as it
sounds it really works I don't focus on
balancing everything I focus on just
making sure that I make progress on one
thing a day that's right you heard me
one thing a day that matters to me now
if I can make progress on one thing a
day that matters to me then I can let go
and let the rest of my day get hijacked
by kids by spouse by phone calls by
emails by social media by all kinds of
things that come up and tend to hijack
your day when you're a busy person when
you have a family when you're married
when you got a lot going on and so by
focusing on one thing a day I feel the
sense of control in the sense of
progress that science tells us will make
you happy and make you feel more
confident and actually make you more
effective at getting things done it also
frees me up to be more present with my
kids the most important work ever if you
have to think of one word that's most
important to you or that sums you Apple
that would be like a little beacon
if you want more Mel Robbins check out
the top fifty rules video I did on her
the link is right there next to me I
think you'll enjoy it continue to
believe and I'll see you there
our minds are designed to stop you at
all costs from doing anything that might
hurt you